321 gaspari
oggi vi dia spezzare costruiremo un
parco giochi in giardino per il nostro
cane berlino
in più sarà un parco giochi speciale
perché sarà un percorso con vane metta
coli varie cose somari divertenti e poi
faremo una gara perché faremo il
percorso di una berlina sia io che è
vitale vedremo alla fine se ho vinto io
oltre a vinto vitale voi potrete
scriversi nei commenti qual è stato
secondo me il momento più divertente di
questa challenge se volete vedere altre
challenge con merlino in cui qualcosa
con berlino e costruiamo qualcosa
lasciato un bel mi piace anzi
consigliate seppur tutte le vostre idee
giù nei commenti mettetevi comodi
prendete i pop corn andiamo a costruire
i percorsi fuori
[Musica]
[Applauso]
meraviglio troppo che dovrei giocare il
tuo parco giochi e fare il percorso sei
pronto a testa finendo di montare le
ultime cose per il parco giochi 32 una
pena
[Applauso]
berlin è andato subito al tiro 5 entra
dentro dentro vertici
[Musica]
ma che stai facendo
berlino 9 giu ma quello è il solito
lavoro
ora vi guido nel parco giochi e percorso
che abbiamo preparato per merlino
innanzi tutto qua ci sono dei pali per
fare lo slalom quindi merlina dovrà fare
lo slalom e poi girerà qua dietro dietro
questo albero e poi dovrà correre
saltare fino dentro il cerchio
[Risate]
[Musica]
poi dopo aver saltato nel cerchio dovrà
entrare dentro al tubo è uscire dal tubo
ciao ciao
secondo voi riuscirà a berlino
completare tutto il percorso
se riuscirà a completare tutto il
percorso lo aspetterà un premio vediamo
se riuscirà a prenderlo dirigenti per
l'evento si è aggiunto anche il pubblico
che sta osservando 6 merlino ce la farà
a superare tutto il percorso
[Applauso]
inizia il percorso vitale con berlino e
poi toccherà a me
vediamo inizia uno slalom attenzione a
un po ho saltato qualche palo merlino ha
saltato qualche modo li vediamo se
riesce a fare il giro sta ricominciando
il percorso da capo vediamo se ce l'ha
fatta è pagata ecco qua che merlino
bravissimo di quadra
vediamo se riesce a fare il salto
[Risate]
[Musica]
berlino ha schivato il cerchio dai
berlino
vediamo se entreranno il tubo ne hanno
fatto uno slalom e il tubo quindi hanno
fatto 100 bravo merlino ora tocca a me
qule merlino vediamo se riesco a fare
più punti di vitale andiamo a perplesso
e 1 e 2 3 mia
[Musica]
nina berlino che conclude di prima
ora vediamo cosa riusciamo a fare il
salto sei pronto berlino apportare
berlino vieni vieni danni perfino salto
dopo berlino nell aria
berlino berlino vuole ma al contrario
perché fa il contrario io a larino
purtroppo abbiamo fatto solo 50 punti
perché abbiamo fatto solo lo slalom e
non ha fatto il salto nel tunnel
quindi non sono stata una brava trainer
invece vitali ha fatto 100 punti ma
questa era solo la corsa di prova ora
facciamo quella ufficiale a tempo siete
pronti
e l'ha fatto al contrario
[Musica]
che qualcuno qui è molto perplesso sulle
reali capacità di berlino infatti sta
schiacciando il pisolino come potete
vedere siamo visione
pronti per il primo round ufficiale ha
inizio il velino scappato beni per circa
32 euro
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bravissimo corradi vitale proprio 321
bravo bravo bravo merlino bravo bravo
bravissimo arrivo bravissimo
berlino grassi dato il salto zampata
bravo bravo bravo bravissimo bravissimo
berlino che ha vinto tutte le sole è
arrivato il momento delle premiazioni
vero giro allora berlino ci fai un
ultimo salto marino rosicky al suo
premio ed è felicissimo berlino lascia
per un pezzo
[Musica]
22 berlino con questo parco giochi ok
ragazzi messi siamo divertiti tantissimo
e anche berlino è stato troppo
divertente questa challenge mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace se
volete vedere altre challans del genere
conseguiremo qualcos'altro per me e
arabi lasciamo bastate a duplicare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite
[Musica]